ficou muito hpe
mano É isso aí família hoje eu vou levar
os meus amigos para jogar golf né a
gente se começar a ficar mais íntimo com
essa essa vida nova que a gente tá
levando né lugares mais ripados e tudo
mais então agora eu gosto sempre da
acensão de levar a galera para poder
fazer um esporte eu falei eu sugeri Poo
Aquático
é
bxa mas eles preferiram o Golf Então
vamos lá eu como bom conhecedor né que
eu já tô nesse nesse Ramo do rico há
muito tempo né o ramo do dinheiro muito
tempo sou conhecedor já fui muito já foi
muito esses vai e vem da vida né
negociar né bater papo jogando no Golf
tal fechar um negócio
n Então vou levar você se você gostar já
peço que você Clique em gostei aí
hein
nó com a luva de
[Música]
golf
é por is gosta D cer sess
co vamos começar não quer nem saber dos
outros
primiro
primeira vez o c mostra aqui meu
chapao
difícil Finger
P
Finger
Caral ele botou uma vez aqui e acertei
lado do
quantas
jardas deixar nem a bola
[Risadas]
parada Caral mano
a simpati com essor jog
terça-feira Ave
Maria ass aqui
embaixo onde foi mano onde é o buraco
mano Realmente você não vê onde vai ali
ó na pedra foi mais
uma ó ele me falou que era assim ó fura
os
dedo bota esse aqui vem com esses e bota
assim ó tá vendo
Ah aí o cara
Mira tenta não sair
senão o
car só que é sem direção porque ela vai
PR lá eu quero botar ali não segura
aí
dedão
vai meter um
balaço achando também é responsa
vai e a luva é o hein Pergunta ele que a
luva
só escorregar escorregar e pode ser em
qualquer uma das mãos ou eu tô usando na
mão
errada é por isso que eu tô acertando
por causa da luva que tá na mão errado
eu sou
Canhoto passa pertinho
assim ó o pezinho girando de trás esse
aqui faz assim também ó irmão
aqui ali lá el vai botar lá na ixe Maria
vai
treta
loucura S [__] Eita [__]
Caral
[__] mano muito [__] Pera aí vou
tentar mais um agora
vai depois passa bora Tá bom
posso são tá fiozinho né calma aí igual
el você precisa também concentrar
somente num agora
aqui Ronaldinho Gaúcho
entendeu
que mano fou da
hora tá filmando go
macha agora é mais mais
de
tô fazendo a segurança do carro forte
aqui frac né agora chegou na hora do
Caio mini golf Ah assim já fic mais
interessante
é toda quarta-feira é ma mentira
viu
[Música]
eu me liguei Eu me liguei isso aqui dá
um ela vai empina eu fiz só um pouco
assim ó ela passou voado tá ligado Então
tem que ser bem sensivel Zinho mano
mha
thank you motador Como como é
motador eu gosto de falar inglês com
quem tenta falar português ou então
posso tentar falar a língua do cara
também né sal Crab
sal de de de cada um tem um né bom
galerinha eu espero que vocês tenham
gostado da gente jogando no Golf é uma
coisa diferente eu acho que na verdade
foi a primeira vez na minha vida que eu
peguei no ta de golfe e ji
quer dizer não me lembro de ter Peg
geralmente onde tem algum lugar a gente
pega PR ver como é né mas não me lembro
não dá uma tacada Com certeza nunca foi
a primeira vez fo bo foi irada não foi
não massa então se você quiser ver mais
rolês diferente você pode sugerir aí nos
comentários e deixar o seu gostei aí pra
gente estamos junto é nós é Lembrando
que tem vídeo tem vídeo ontem tem vídeo
amanhã e tem vídeo hoje então você pode
sempre entrar no canal que vai ter uns
dois três vídeos que vocês não viram
vocês não queria vídeo por agora tem
vídeo agora então vamos embora agora vou
pro meu quarto um banco já já tem treino
de novo aí depois tem outro vídeo de
treino PR vocês é sempre assim né e eu
não posso deixar de agradecer o nosso
hotel que tá dando aqui tudo pra gente
aqui a sfl Ava Exatamente é ela é a
esposa do Nate E ela e eles são São
donos desse hotel aqui cham a gente para
treinar na Tailândia E se a gente
quisesse podia ficar aqui e onde é que
nós estamos E como foi que eu joguei
Golf pela primeira vez massa viu
Obrigado viu o nome do hotel é softel
Crab é um é um spa né gigante res um
resort né tem a
maior piscina da Ásia Se não me engano
uma das maiores ou é a maior mesmo se
não me engano esse hotel aqui que nós
estamos esse resor aqui que a gente tá é
o sexto mais top da Tailândia esse hotel
que a gente tá aqui tá entre os 10 mais
top da Tailândia então se você vier pra
Tailândia vem aí Crab Não deixe de
visitar tiver em Bangkok tem também
vamos nessa Mas vamos lá p puxar V puxar
vou
puxar
ai gente foi top esse final né clica em
gostei aí a galera clicar muito em
gostei comentar muito eu
most todo
mes